But I often found out that I was the yuki-onna at that time My
face and whiteness haven't changed Is it a mistake
?
That's not bad, you
know me well It's
been more than 10 years since then, and your face should have changed as you look older, but you're the
only person I remember helping you recently.  It's not like I'm looking at people in the middle of the night There
are signs and colors that don't change easily
[music]  I
can buy
dozens of soft-serve ice cream that have
increased.
I don't know about cards, service days, or other people's calendars. If you're with me, I
can go into the store and choose items slowly, and I won't get lost.  Yes It's
suitable for eating without worrying about others
[music] I've
become quite good at cooking since I got divorced last year